[Musique]
alors j'ai fait une connerie j'ai dit
clairement tout de suite à la maison à
temps calme toi calme toi qu'est-ce qui
se passe
allô allô
jessica
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé si tu es
quelqu'un joue quoi quoi tu as tu veux
qu'ils ne peuvent pas parler pour
l'instant scène il faut que tu m'aides à
me débarrasser du corrigé dans le pays
et pourquoi attend explique moi ce qui
s'est passé je n'ai jamais dit que je ne
pouvais pas à parler
bon je vais aller en prison je veux pas
aller en prison je veux pas long je
croyais que tu m'aimais ok je vais
t'aider
d'accord ça va aller d'accord c'est pour
ça qu'on est assez bien plus tôt
effectivement d'un certain
[Musique]
et
à troyes d'accord 1 2
[Musique]
bravo bravo bravo justice à mettre vous
amassez pour jeter à corps un cadavre de
nuit dans un canal selon en pleine nuit
c'est formidable ça peut être un petit
commentaire
pas de commentaire c'est lui qui a très
bien l'équipe de feu ma confiance est
très très heureuse de vous offrir cette
somme de 10000 euros voilà j'étais môme
à moi c'est mes beaux jours de ma vie
est ce que tu veux m'épouser de super
vous aussi vous trouvez piégé contre
mecque pour savoir si vous aiment
vraiment envoyez nous un sms au 7 43 43
ou retrouvez nous sur twitter avec le
hashtag fais moi confiance
bonne soirée et à la semaine prochaine
la semaine prochaine on fais moi
confiance ne manquez pas chérie j'ai
mangé ton père chéri j'ai mangé ton père